Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast farm by day,
October,
October 2nd oh my God.
Get out your fucking Barracuda Dude.
It's the fucking fall.
So officially the fall,
isn't it lovely?
Honda's leaves turning different colors,
falling off the trees and crunching under your feet.
Halloween comes and then Thanksgiving and it'll be good.
75 80 degrees with whatever,
but the oceans rising,
but whatever's going very interesting.
It's gonna be very interesting.
False.
I feel coming up.
Oh,
do you feel it,
bill?
Was this your own idea?
Did you stick your head out the window and assess it or did you listen to a
bunch of Shit on TV?
I ride.
She got me.
You got me.
But it is the fall,
the falls,
one of my favorite seasons,
what I loved about the fall was the beginning of the school year and I
absolutely loved school.
I just,
when I was a child,
I craved knowledge.
I don't know what it was like.
Of course the other kids wanted to go outside and play and gaging contests of
sport,
but not me.
No,
I just wanted to curl up in the corner.
Just couldn't just,
the mother just couldn't get me enough books.
I know that was obviously,
um,
it was obviously in a non truth.
None of that was true.
Uh,
what I liked about the fall was I got new clothes for school,
you know,
which back then was you got your hand me downs from your brother and you got a
new pair of sneakers.
All right.
And uh,
they were new until the first time it fucking rained or something happened and
then they would just,
you know,
that was it.
And those were your sneakers for a year.
You're wore sneakers for a year.
Your mother bought him like a half size or a full size too big dependent.
We know.
She was trying to gauge,
you know,
when your balls we're going to drop to considering how big your feet we're going
to be.
Right.
It was one of those,
you know,
one of those things back then it was like nine grades all in one class,
not fuck a book.
Um,
I liked the new sneakers in the new clothes and whatever.
You hand me down shit that I got from my older brother.
And then,
uh,
and then it was football and then also it was starting to get cold so I didn't
have to deal with any more.
Dude,
look out why your fucking legs are,
I didn't have to deal with that with the summer.
I didn't have to deal with sunburns.
I liked it.
I was more of a fucking winter guy.
Um,
but other than that,
everything else sucked by fucking arc.
180 days of school to go.
Can you believe that?
You used to think that that was hard and he actually used to fuck up in school
if you would like me.
I always look back.
It's just like,
why don't I just come home?
Why don't you just pay attention,
come home and just do my homework.
I could've gone to like a really good college like,
and,
and to me a good college is,
it has,
it has a sports program that I can follow.
It's one and you know,
they battled for fucking at least a win their conference.
You know what I mean?
I don't fucking,
I dunno,
I don't fucking like
these college you should go to where everybody is.
I don't know what it is like to take Vanderbilt and the SEC,
by the way.
Who played a hell of a fucking game this weekend,
right?
Scared the shit out of Florida.
Um,
I always thought that,
you know,
I wish I always assumed that that school sucked because their football team was
no good for so long.
Now they're actually halfway decent.
But I judge schools by how good their sports program is.
And you know,
there's a lot of people on real sports are one of those shows that,
you know,
everybody wears suits and for some reason they have a pen but they never really
writing,
you know,
those shows that take it really seriously in the like,
what does that say?
What are the civil,
the educational system that people judge a school by their sports programs?
Well,
no,
this you fucking pencil,
push and nerd.
There would be no campus without sports.
Okay.
How did that fill a stadium?
And that money goes right back into the school,
doesn't it?
God knows it's not paying the players.
All right.
And that's why when you go to the University of Michigan,
it's its own fucking city.
It's not because of the science department.
Oh,
the engineers that know how to build the buildings.
It's cause the big blue down the fucking street polo and they pulled in a
hundred,
400,
500,
10,000 people a Goddamn game.
That's what pays for it.
You know,
even if it's not all that money,
they level of attention.
And that makes people all around the world,
you know?
No.
That song hail to the victors,
valiant,
hail to the victors.
Fucking get on a raft,
get over here and go to that school.
Right.
Is that how it goes?
I Dunno.
Um,
I know what the fuck was I talking about?
Why I like the fall?
Yeah.
I just,
what fucked did I study?
So fucking stupid.
I can't believe.
I can't imagine if I actually understood calculus,
what my fa,
what my world would be like right now
by just took the time to fuck.
I mean,
it's not like they just dumped it all on you the first day.
I forget when I stopped paying attention somewhere around seventh grade,
I just was like,
Eh,
I'm just not into this.
MMM.
Oh my God.
I could have studied and then I can do one of those extra curricular things and
got like a scholarship,
you know,
participated in a bunch of other shit.
I would have had that all fleshed out.
I see you're on the debating team.
You're on the swimming team and I'll let shit remember those fucking kids.
The kid next to his locker was like neat,
you know?
And it wasn't all dented and shit.
Fucking always had his homework or like sweaters,
you know,
you'd just be looking at him like kind of fine.
As fucked as this person is,
like my age.
And they have their shit that together.
Oh,
he's in a thousand papers falling out of my fucking,
there just was a mess.
And every year I'd be like,
Hey,
this is year I'm going to study,
I'm going to fuck in my drawn all over my books.
I'm going to pay attention,
I'm going to try to get all A's and B's.
That's all.
That's all I wanted to do and I just,
I couldn't do it.
I put up a good fight through about,
I get to about September 10th
then I get like that first fucking c,
c,
c.
What's that?
What's that a reference to?
Speaking of moving look movie lines.
Si,
SI,
Si.
Was it summer rentals for summer school there it was.
The Guy who's been on TV for 40 years but never does interviews.
So people kind of Mark Harmon,
is that his name?
Who was that guy like chainsaws,
some shit and of course they made the Latino girl pregnant cause you could still
do that back then.
You can't do that now.
You get called out on it.
They would never do that now.
Now they would make the white guy pregnant
to show that they're progressive.
That's how it would work.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing wrong with having a Latina woman be pregnant,
but when she's the only Latino in the fucking movie,
that's when it becomes a problem.
Oh.
So she's going to summer school and she's knocked up and she's dressed like
fucking zebra man and heavy metal parking lot.
Do you know?
I'd never seen that.
I thought that was an entire fucking movie and ice for years.
I was like,
I got to get around to watch and heavy metal parking lot.
I never fucking saw it.
And finally somebody referenced it again.
Um,
oh,
I know why.
Dean del Ray from the let there be talk all things,
comedy network podcast.
He sent me a link and one of Judas Priest's guitarist,
uh,
who that those cake cake downing and Glen Tipton I think is Glen Tipton.
He bought,
I hope I'm saying his name right.
He bought a fucking Porsche in 1985 or 86 he went to the factory when he was on
tour and that's back when they made them.
Hey,
there was hand built.
None of this robot shit.
None of this outsourcing it to fucking whatever the fuck they do it now.
Um,
they were handbill okay.
By the same people that brought your audio tape
in World War One and World War Two.
All right.
It was fucking,
they were hand fucking built.
It's right at the same people brought you October fest and the Holocaust,
you know what I mean?
They,
they,
they're all over the map over there.
That's why Germany is still such a scary country.
It's like what's going to happen over here?
Are we all gonna get drink beers and get shit faced or are you guys going to try
to take over the world again?
You know,
that's what's on their weather channel
as a monitor.
All the psychos over there.
What are the,
what is,
what is the general population planning right now or possibly a small group of
really motivated people within Deutschland.
So anyways,
I had never seen heavy metal parking lot.
I thought it was a full movie.
So I sit down to watch it right out of the gate.
I love it.
Cause the concerts at the cap center and that's where I used to watch the,
uh,
you know,
whenever the broad used to play,
when they've gone out and play the capitols.
And they had rod language looked like my math teacher back in the day.
Man,
my math teacher was a dead fucking ringer.
Flunked his class two fucking years in a row.
It was two summers.
I'll never get back.
Actually my senior year,
I didn't fucking go to some schools like,
well,
what's the point?
I can't get into a school that has a good foot,
you know,
football program or basketball program.
They don't have no sports here,
so fuck it.
Uh,
anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Yeah.
So I'm watching this thing.
So they had the cap center,
which I never really saw what it looked like because they never really showed
the outside that I can remember there just be the birds that I,
they would cap center Berry Peterson leading the league with 40 some goals,
a great year.
We had,
um,
and we traded in my belief.
Um,
so I got to watch this fucking thing and,
uh,
I've gotta be honest with you.
Like the memories that came flying back,
first of all,
my first concert ever was Judas priest with doc and opening up.
Of course it was dark and they fucking open for everybody.
Day Open for everybody.
And Tesla Open for fucking and Cinderella opened for fucking everybody.
MMM.
That was my first on the Turbo Lover Tour.
Right.
And I guess I found out all these years later that that Judas priest guide Glen
Tipton or whatever,
but a fucking Porsche that was a turbo and he loved it so much that he's
fucking,
you know,
it was inspired to write a song and then a rob Halford took it in whatever
direction he wanted to take it in.
You know,
that we remember that song a Hob,
your turbo lava make no sense.
Right?
You won't see me
then.
Yeah.
Uh,
Joe feel me.
Oh,
like crazy music.
Right.
Um,
I saw them on that tour.
So anyway,
so I watch that heavy metal parking lot and um,
I was fucking great.
That's exactly what I mean.
Whoever fucking film that I know I'm way,
way,
way past the whole.
Everybody knows that by now.
We have a film that thank,
thank you so much for filming that
I do.
The first time I ever saw anybody do blow,
I went to an ACDC concert and I remember I pulled up my big stupid red fucking
hair.
Right.
You know,
and I can't grow it long.
My hair just grew out so I,
I was like,
I missed it,
man.
I should've come up in the 70s I would have been fine.
We've been rocking that Bernie from room to 22 but you know,
everybody kind of had this shit,
you know,
I dunno what the fuck it was in the 80s wasn't short,
but it wasn't long.
It was right before the mullets feathered.
Everything was feathered.
Farrah Fawcett was so hot.
Even the guys tried to have their hair like curse.
Right.
That's what was going on.
And me,
I was just like,
you know,
I was a man without a splitter,
without a fucking country.
So I would pull up,
you know,
not a whisker on my face.
I have a fucking pull up my stupid fucking looking like I swear to God looking
like a giant Opie Taylor and uh,
and I was totally into the music but I just look like a fucking freak,
you know,
I should have grown my,
I go actually I couldn't grow my house assessed should at least go on the
Malakai route and just been drunk enough and just got out of the car and
screamed Outlander and then everybody will left me on loan.
I remember I pulled up to the ACDC tig and this fucking guy was doing blow and
he had a Toyota pickup truck rusted out.
Of course back then everything fucking Rustin,
especially the Toyota hunters hunks of shit.
But the engines would never die.
Right.
You'd be part driving down the street.
You could literally see the fucking engine still working.
So it's guy gets out of the car
and I'm like looking at him like I know we like to same kind of music,
but we are not the same person.
I remember he was fucking,
yeah,
this blond hair look and he cut his own hair.
It was like some like a fucked up page boy haircut
and like a perm all at the same time.
And like he turned around and through the line and then fucking came right up to
my window as I pulled up looking like a fucking,
I don't know,
I felt like I was in one of those zoos where the animals aren't in a cage,
you know,
he just came up and he just was like,
eh.
And I was kind of like,
hey man,
fortunate I was with somebody else.
And I think that we were listening to who made,
who would a very respectable volume.
Um,
yeah,
that was the who made,
who went in loudness,
opened up a Japanese heavy metal band.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about here.
Let's,
let's,
let's get into the podcast.
I'm just sort of meandering here.
Um,
why don't we talk a little bit of NFL football.
We love,
we've got to talk college first.
All right.
So what I watched,
I watched,
uh,
I watched Texas tech against,
um,
Oklahoma state.
What a fucking great game that was.
And what an atmosphere out there in Lubbock,
Texas.
I got to go to what Texas Tech Gay man.
So I was actually out there.
I was looking up theaters to see if they had a little s theater I could play
maybe next year or whatever during football season.
You know,
anybody can go to Dallas.
Right.
I've already been to Texas A and M and I've been to the Texas longhorns.
The next big program is Texas Tech.
Right.
Of course they'll give you shit at Baylor.
Smu,
they never recovered from the fucking death penalty,
but what else they got out there?
I think that's it.
So,
um,
I was rooting for Texas tech cause I know I just,
just cause they were the underdog but was such a fucking great game.
And I was flipping back and forth,
you know,
my adopted college team,
Lsu fucking tigers,
you know,
we lost again,
but you know,
we lost it,
the Trojans.
So that's okay.
You know,
that's how I say it to people.
we lost this week to the Trojans.
I thought USC last two.
Uh,
all they did.
I was talking about the Troy Trojans from the very formidable sun belt
conference.
I was embarrassed as a new Lsu fan.
I became an Lsu fan about nine years ago and as a,
uh,
adopted team to see all those fucking people leave the fucking stadium emptied
out with eight minutes to go.
All right.
Granted they needed three scores,
but,
uh,
I,
I didn't like that at all.
I hate seeing that.
And then I was at that point just ruling that they came back and won just so all
those fucking cunts would have to lie on Monday and say that they,
they were part of the 40 people that still stuck around.
But,
um,
I'm trying to think what was worse watching Lsu lose to Troy or the Troy Trojans
helmets,
you know,
everything has to look like fucking,
I dunno,
you know,
that,
you know that on that Awful Candy and movie theaters that they only sell it at
movie theaters,
whatever those fucking things are.
I don't mean gummy bears.
Do you have a good friend of mine that loves gummy bears?
Guy Friend?
It just,
I dunno,
it just,
it almost fucks up our friendship,
you know,
like when,
when he's kind of bugging me,
whatever.
I just kind of think every once in a while it gets fucking guy likes gummy
bears.
I'll do what?
I love going to movies,
you know,
I fucking love going to movies.
I take my kids,
you know,
get a box of gummy bears,
gummy bears.
Um,
yeah,
the fucking Oregon ducks.
All right.
Those greening yellow cons,
they fucked it up for everybody.
They were the first ones to put the disco ball on their head and now everybody's
doing it.
I'm calling it right now.
Those fucking things are going to look,
they're going to look fucking ridiculous in years to come.
People will be like,
what in the Pfizer and electric is that thing like plugged in or some shit?
Some of them are cool.
I guess.
I don't know what,
but I,
I love how the MLB,
this year they went back to the,
uh,
like they went to like this non gloss matte color on the batting helmets.
They look fucking mean as hell,
man.
I'm mean as hell,
Um,
so anyways,
that's what the fuck I watched and I'm done.
I watch pro football today.
Ooh,
JJ,
Jj,
the New England patriots with their second loss of the year.
Um,
pardon me and joys that they lost twice because it keeps all the fucking pray.
It'd be nice to have a nice fucking anticipation free a season,
you know?
And when you're two and two,
God knows nobody's fucking looking at you now.
Uh,
how about that defense?
Huh?
The fuck
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you right now,
if you want to score 30 points,
you got to go to New England.
I'm trying to,
I should look this up like we gave up,
I think we gave up 75 points in the first two games and then we added another 30
today.
Is that what happened?
Let's look at the Patriots here.
Let's look at the sad,
sad tale and I can't figure out what the fuck is going on.
I mean how many yards have we given up this year on,
on just like blown coverages that fucking fake screen pass.
Like the entire defense on that side bites on it.
You know,
if you look around corners and our safety's,
it's still butler Chung McCourty.
Those guys have been playing together for years.
I don't know how long we've had the Gilmore Guy,
but I like that guy.
That guy hits hard,
he knocked somebody out of the game,
he had another good hit you a bullshit hands to the face and then a brutal one.
But a,
we shouldn't have been in that situation to begin with.
But,
um,
our offense is fine me course.
I would love if our offensive line could give him a little Brady a little more
time.
Um,
he's definitely taken too many hits,
but we're still scoring points.
But our defense,
Jesus Christ,
not really stopping the run,
not really getting pressure on the quarterback blown fucking coverages.
But,
uh,
I just feel like the blown coverage,
is that something that,
you know,
Matt,
Patricia can work on,
right?
He can get those guys like three of the four of them.
It's just like,
you guys want to fucking Superbowl last year.
I'm not,
I don't know all the patriots,
so I don't know when Gail Morgan on the fucking team.
Um.
All right,
let's look at Patriot's here.
patriots.com I should have gone schedule,
right?
Is that what I should've done it.
This is going to take for fucking ever patriots schedule.
All right,
here we go.
Patriot schedule.
They're going to go download this schedule when,
okay,
so we let up 42 points the first week.
Then we were on the road,
only led up 20.
Then we let up 33 and we let up 33 again.
Those are all at fucking up.
No,
two of those were home.
Three of those were home.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
33 36 42 I think.
I Dunno,
I just glance at those numbers.
Wait,
(333) 034-0220 thank God for the 20.
All right.
42 and 20 is 62 so that's 31.
So we're averaging like fucking,
I dunno,
30 I guess.
32 points a fucking game.
Yeah.
Todd,
right?
No,
you're not going to go far in the fucking playoffs.
Um,
by the way,
my fucking football pick came in.
I called it the fucking giants getting three against Tampa Bay.
Dude,
I fucking called it.
I told you,
granted the giants didn't fucking win,
but they only lost by two.
Um,
and as a Patriot Fan,
I hate that the giants are owned fourth,
more so than I hate the fact that we're two and two,
because I wanted to play the giants again.
The Superbowl,
the fucking beat.
Those passed.
It's one time when you're [inaudible] we got nothing to lose.
The giants got everything to lose.
They got shit talking rights right now.
You just got to say,
hey,
you guys fucking owners,
right?
By the way,
somebody tweet you like to do.
And what was the last,
have you guys even fucking beat us?
I went to a home game or an away game.
I'm sorry.
Giants.
We fucking beat u of a,
I dunno,
the last time we played you in the regular season in your fucking house,
you can't,
it's fucking guys bragging about preseason games.
It's like,
dude,
you won two super bowls.
That's all you give a fuck about.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
so that's my one picks.
So now I'm going to make another pick on Thursday.
All right.
That'd be,
that'd be Thursday.
I'm going to do my NFL pick of the week now.
What's is what you have to thank for your fucking degenerate Gambler,
you know good.
And God damn well,
I have just as much chance with the information that I'm using of picking a
winner as a housewife who doesn't watch a game.
Okay.
So this first week,
I'm not going to say it was dumb luck.
I was going on fucking how many points the giant scored against the eagles.
I know the score and I'm late.
And then Eli Manning,
who's ripped my heart out twice,
showed it to me and then very politely aided and did get any blood on his
Docker's right?
I was like,
there's no fucking way that these guys,
and I thought that they want to come away with a wind.
I did Buccaneers.
Look,
Greg,
God bless him by the way.
Who the fuck is this?
Ron Funches guy on the,
on the,
uh,
on,
Carolina fucking panthers.
Guy was killing us all day long.
I was,
I don't pray for injuries,
but when his leg cramped up,
I was like,
thank God.
Then he came back out again,
caught another first down second.
We get that fucking guy out of here.
Um,
so anyways,
that's what I was basing it on.
So I'm going to pick another one on Thursday and then you the degenerate
gambler.
You gotta be wondering.
We'll all freckles.
Will he get lucky two weeks in a row?
Because now I'm in your head because I won last week.
This is like playing roulette,
like gone,
right?
The last time was black.
Is it going to be another black or is it going to be a red?
Do I sit out this week?
See,
if it goes to blacks and row,
then I know it's going to be red.
All right.
No,
it was red this week.
I'm a fucking goddamn ginger.
All right.
But with that guy,
fucking,
he didn't pay his taxes.
Always been on black.
Always been on red.
Um,
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say that might be the Photoshop of this week.
It's too fucking easy.
Right?
That's a movie poster right there.
Always bet on red.
I don't know who's playing next week.
So how about those fucking La Ramps,
not your same old rams.
Fucking win,
win and win and beat the Dallas fucking cowboys.
Jesus Christ.
They're going to have their fucking heads in a new south there.
Um,
all right,
well let's get down to it.
Oh,
Billy fucking booze bag is back.
I fell off the wagon.
I couldn't do it.
I'm fucking with you.
I'm still on the fucking wagon.
I went to Vegas and I passed that test.
I was at the,
uh,
the Monte Carlo,
not the race.
The fucking casino stayed over at the MGM Grand Cause they're doing some,
uh,
construction,
I guess on the Monte Carlo.
So they had me across the street and uh,
oh my God,
what a fucking,
no way.
There's,
there's no better people watch it then when you go to Vegas,
Holy Shit.
I went down to the pool.
Yes.
I went down to the poor.
I was working with partner Nick.
He's an Italian guy.
He actually has pigments.
So he wanted to go down the pools,
like had fucking,
I'm not going to stay in the room the whole time.
So I go down to the God damn pool dude.
And it was like,
right,
this is,
the sun had already started to go down.
It was on the other side of the casino.
So there really wasn't any sun on the water.
So there was maybe five or six young people there and everybody else was my
generation or older and Holy Shit,
I know this is a hacky topic.
I know this is,
but thank God I never got a tattoo.
Thank fucking Christ.
If you saw these fucking people and they're my age men,
49 years old,
no shirt on,
all these fucking chicks with their ankle sorority tattoos telling kids what to
do with tattoos,
you know what I mean?
And then that good debt,
what kills me about the tattoo becoming mainstream was the incredible like lack
of research that most people did.
Their total lack of respect
for the art form
and the complete lack of respect for themselves
to go out and try to actually find somebody good at it.
I gotta tell you,
I must have seen 500 fucking tattoos on about a hundred different people down
there.
At the pool.
Everybody just tatted up.
Shit show man boobs are just pex sagging down.
You know,
women,
you always got to give a pass because they have,
they have to bear children.
All right,
but guys,
man,
there's no fucking reason.
You just keep doing the pushups.
Keep the chest high and tight.
What the fuck are you doing?
Lay off the pizza and the boots.
She's fucking guys just walking around out there,
saggy chest and the fucking tribal band,
the tramp stamps.
It was sorority ankle tattoos.
Just fucking horrific.
I went down there and was just sitting there,
just reminded of my own mortality going like,
Jesus Christ.
I really want to fucking act like I'm above these people,
but like,
you know,
smartest fucking thing I that I,
I didn't do was I never got a tattoo.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Thank Christ.
I never did it.
You know,
I like it used to be back in the,
you know,
cause look at me.
I'm not a tattoo guy.
All right,
tattoo,
they got to go back to bad asses.
You know what I mean?
Guys in biker gangs or in prison or like chicks who not a shoot pool and wet
leather pants.
Right.
Hey Amanda,
my fucking mind.
So we went down there and we just looked at that fucking see a humanity and then
this guy just comes out just screaming about how he lost 20 grant and he had a
big grin on his face.
He goes,
throw me in the pool.
I can't swim.
Maybe I'll drown.
I just thought it's 20 grand.
I just saw it's 20 grand in there.
And I looked down,
it was like,
that fucking guy doesn't have 20 grand.
There's no fucking way he's got 20 grand.
And who fucker walks ease?
He's just acting like he's a big shot,
right?
Maybe dead.
I have no fucking idea.
So,
um,
and we went over,
we did the show and after the show we sat out by this giant air conditioning
duct behind a wall on a picnic table and smoke cigars.
And it was great.
And I didn't participate at all in the Vegas Shenanigans.
I knew enough when I walked through the lobby and I saw the people,
all the young people.
So this is their time.
Don't be the creepy guy hanging around,
ruining it,
get the fuck outta here.
So I went back over to the MGM,
walked back and a,
I got back probably about 1230 at night and that was that first wave of women
that had had enough,
you know,
two out of three of them are walking barefoot,
carrying their horse shoes,
right?
What happens in Vegas stays in Vegas and they just had dirty feet just walking
to the f with a giant fucking drink.
And uh,
I was glad that I stayed.
I did stay out of that and I didn't booze,
although I did smoke a fucking cigar and a kind of did it on an empty stomach
and I got a minute,
I was a little fucking nauseous cause was this giant Cuban and the next day we
took the helicopter out and back and on the way back there was like a 17 to 30
knot wind dependent on what altitude we were until we really got down low flying
over the 15.
It got down to like nine knots and we're kind of getting pushed around a little
bit up there.
And there was a couple of times I was like,
oh my God,
feeling a little Nazi stuff here.
You know,
that's not what you want to see from your pilot asking for a puke bag.
I mean,
the most comforting thing he could say at that point,
you know,
it's all right.
It's all right.
I,
I drank last night,
so,
um,
anyways,
but I gotta tell you man,
flying out there,
taking the helicopter and going over the Moh Javvi desert.
MMM.
Was it was,
it was fucking incredible.
The desert is so it's like beautiful,
terrifying,
boiling,
hot and freezing all at the same time.
It's just fucking a,
I swear to God,
I don't know why.
You know what's something that people thought we faked the moon landing.
This is probably where they went,
right?
The power just went out to the desert.
You know a lot of mountains though.
I don't think they faked it,
man.
I think they going,
I think they got up there.
I have it gives a fuck.
Maybe they didn't.
There's so much shit for me to fucking babble about.
Did you guys wants to Formula One at all?
Huh?
Anybody see it in any way?
She ate it all.
Uh,
what do I have it here?
It gets to the fucking standings.
I know.
What's his face?
One from red bull.
Red Bull had to fucking cars and I can now,
I always want to say I always fuck up that guy's name.
The fuck is his name.
Who wanted this?
Who won the race today?
The fuck's his name.
What is his name?
Max for staffing.
Once I think Sebastian Vettel.
I can't think for staffing cause that v like my brain can only handle one v word
a minute or the same letter.
I'm telling you,
I have this,
I don't know what the fuck my deal is.
Um,
but this is the first race that I saw.
We're Lewis Hamilton or,
or uh,
Valtteri Botox in the Mercedes teams.
One of either one of them.
If they,
if they're in first fucking place going into the turn,
the Mercedes cars are just too goddamn good.
Maybe a Ferrari can run him down.
I've never fucking seen it,
but red bull,
this was their day.
This was their track.
They were amazing.
Lewis Hamilton got into fucking the first,
it was the first person that came out in the lead.
I can't even talk this fucker podcasts.
I apologize.
Um,
came on to the first turn in the lead and as far as my year and a half of
watching the shit,
that means you're going to win the race,
especially if you're in a Mercedes and um,
for staff.
And actually came right up on him and went right around them like it was
nothing.
And then opened up like an eight,
nine second lead on them.
I have,
I've never seen that.
I'm a Mercedes,
humbled like that by red bull.
So congratulations.
Then Daniel Ricardo came in third place and,
uh,
Lewis Hamilton,
fucking steady,
steady Eddie there,
still got second place.
He's got 281 fucking point.
Sebastian Vettel for whatever fucking reason.
Ferrari.
I don't know what they're doing.
My daughter had her first cold man,
so I was kind of watching her.
So I missed the beginning.
All the sudden Kimmy raking it in at some going on with his turbo and he didn't
even fucking drive and Sebastian Vettel was way in the back,
so I'm going to guess,
uh,
either fucked up during the time trials and it got some sort of penalty or they
had to switch out a gearbox.
There's some shit that puts you at the back of the race.
You're only allowed to use so many parts,
so many engines or something like that,
um,
throughout the season.
So he was all the way in the back.
He was able to work himself all the way up to fourth place.
Um,
which was really impressive.
Uh,
but now he is,
be as,
what does he got?
He's 34 fucking points.
I mean,
I don't think that they'd make it up after that debacle in Singapore,
that absolute fucking three stooges fucking debacle.
I don't think that they make it up,
but it was very exciting as a new fan of Formula One to actually see somebody
enforced first place and get passed to actually see a Mercedes Benz in first
place and get past it gave me hope.
That Formula One can be more like that.
Um,
the way moto GP is.
All right.
Um,
anyway,
so let's get to some of the reeds here for the week.
Uh,
some of the,
actually some of the advertising here,
shall we,
uh,
have a popup?
Where is it?
Ah,
look who's here?
Pro Flowers.
Oh No,
wait,
wait.
Did I cut that off?
This podcast?
It just fucking blows.
What am I doing today?
Oh,
look,
goes here.
Me.
Andy died.
Oh,
doto be Andy's beyond ease.
Bill can't fucking read to do,
to do Mondays.
BMDS mass is starting to bleed,
but thank God I got fucking silk down by my tank and my balls.
Who fucking cares if I'm bleeding from the cheeses pill?
That's not,
that's just disgusting.
You already know me.
Undies makes the most comfortable underwear in the world.
It fun to wear isn't your thing,
man.
We're excited to announce that me undies socks are finally here.
Be ready for work,
play and everything in between with the new me undies.
Socks.
If you thought your balls felt good,
if you thought your balls thanked you every week,
wait to see you here.
What your toe say?
Biondi socks are now available.
Yoni socks are spun from premium materials making their socks the best you can
get for your feet.
Talk about why me undies is the best underwear and socks you will ever own.
Well they pay me to say so and a,
I have a daughter and she wants to go to college one day and who knows how long
I sell tickets so I might as well say that these guys have the best underwear
and socks beyond.
These will be the most comfortable pair of underwear and now socks you will ever
own exclusive offer.
Right now [inaudible] has an exclusive offer just for our listeners and whoever
else they advertise with.
Get 20% off your first order and free shipping.
BMDS is so sure you will love their underwear and socks.
They will give you a 100%
I just pictured somebody taking the s,
you know when someone dries himself off with the towel and they dry off their
undercarriage,
just doing that with the sox during the commercial going,
oh my God,
they feel amazing.
You just zoom in and zoom it out really quickly,
you know to get that effect so you can't really see the junk.
You just see.
See the sock.
Right,
and it's so fucking weird that the millennials buy it.
Why do we get millennials so much shit?
You know what I mean?
My generation should.
They should give like people la,
the generation older than me,
shit for raising them.
Is that right?
I don't know.
Right now.
Mandy has an exclusive offer.
Just for our listeners be entities is so sure you will love their underwear and
socks.
They will give you a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Simply order a pair.
If you don't like it,
get a full refund.
This is a no brainer,
20% off free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
What are you waiting for him?
Yonnie's dot com slash [inaudible] dot com slash bar a pro flowers just in time
for Halloween.
If you know any of those people who are,
you know,
if you know any of those people who are obsessed with fall,
things like pumpkin spice lattes and scented candles.
Pro Flowers has the perfect gift.
It's called the ass vase.
You take a fucking long stem rose.
No,
a long lasting bouquet and their favorite fall colors,
their bestselling cinnamon fighter.
Roses are a great option for a birthday and anniversary.
Any fall occasion or go with one of the classics like 100 autumn blooms are a
dozen autumn roses.
Well,
I don't understand what it fuck buys flowers in October.
It's the end.
Don't they die this time a year?
You buy them in the spring hundred autumn balloons?
Well when they fucking,
they turn colors cause they can't breathe anymore.
You can't lose because no matter which bouquet bouquet you send,
my listeners get 20% off of any of the pro flowers.
Unique bouquets for $29 a more.
Is this way you buy like that fucking,
it looks like something you'd yell through,
but it's really,
it's made.
It's made like a basket weaving class and there's a bunch of shit fallen out of
it and usually it's squash
pro flowers.
Bouquets are guaranteed to stay fresh for at least seven days or your money back
and you control the delivery date.
Pro Flowers gives you more bloom for your buck.
Big beautiful flowers.
More stems for your money and long lasting freshness to get 20% off all the
bouquets for $29 and more,
go to pro flowers and used my code burr,
but you are,
that's proflowers.com code named Burr.
What does that fucking thing called?
Okay,
let's do a search here.
Thanksgiving
horn thing,
basket squash.
See if this gets anything.
Bam.
A cornucopia.
That's a cornucopia basket.
Look at that.
I nailed it.
Thanksgiving horn thing.
Basket squash got me there.
All right.
Dollars Dollar Shave Club.
You Dude.
Uh,
what you might not know is that dollar shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the bathroom.
Body Wash,
shampoo,
Hair Gel,
lip balm,
herpes medicine,
everything at the store,
that crab comb at the store.
There are too many options and you can't tell the difference between any of
them.
If it's a brush or things for my taint,
why is it always go to the taint?
I Dunno.
Uh,
then if you have any questions,
the clerk usually doesn't know the difference either or can't really help you
sense they are not an expert on the products or maybe they just have one person
working there.
Like my experience in fucking cvs and Dwayne Reed,
they run a skeleton shift in the middle of the fucking day.
Uh,
now you don't have to step foot in a store to get high quality to get a high
quality shave and grooming products.
A dollar shave club delivers them right to your door.
Pube tremors.
There's something else.
This is like the family feud named something you'd find in a bathroom.
Johnson family,
uh,
pube tremors,
show me puke trainers.
Now we'd be like the fourth answer.
Everybody claps,
you know,
and as they go like the authority and the intelligence slowly starts to drop.
You know,
maybe if they have an artist in the family that last family members are right,
but when they get down to that last person,
who else do we fucking break?
You know?
Um,
anyways,
where am I as a,
for a limited time,
dollar shave club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower shave started set to new members for only $5 to start a set features the
executive razor and three trial size versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean.
I'm so fresh and so clean.
In your first box you will receive their shave butter,
bodywash and one wipe Charlies.
Oh chary but wipes one wipe Charlie,
but wipes.
Um,
I've never used those one wipe and you get it all.
I don't know about that.
I Dunno about that.
You will also receive
even like the cocaine shits,
the coke shits I always hear about because it's been cut with laxative.
That's should be the test on the commercial when they do the one white.
But uh,
one wipe Charlies but shite but wipes.
I just,
I don't why can't talk today you'll also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full cassette of cartridges.
Can I give you guys advice on a safety razor?
When you have a weighted handle?
Do not pull it across your face,
hold it lightly and let gravity with the weight of the handle.
Bring it down across your face.
If you don't,
you're gonna cut yourself.
You will also receive their executive razor,
which includes I or just said that after the first box replacement cartridges
are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offers exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar
uh,
that's dollar shave club.com/bart Dollar Shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There's no better time to try the club.
All right.
I swear to God,
this is the last one.
And I love stamps.com because they know I can't read,
so they always make it nice and quick.
Stamp,
stop,
calm.
Everybody stamps save you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business or stare at your balls.
I can mail any letter and package just using my computer and my printer and the
mailman comes and picks it up.
She's actually a lady and she's really offended.
Avoid the hassle of the post office and mail everything from the postcards,
from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes,
right.
Just like the whore up this straight,
it never caught the horse legs up the street.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven keyboard slash.
Descriptors.
Convenient,
easy,
reliable and flexible.
Just like the horror up the street.
I use stamps.com because include your personal recommendation.
Um,
I had a baby tooth left in my head and it finally fell out.
And I,
uh,
use stamps.com to mail it back to my mother when she sent me a quarter.
And right now,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstampsdotcomenterburrstamps.com.
Never go to the post office again.
All right.
Is that it?
Is that it for the reading?
Um,
what else did I want to talk about that I handle everything I think I did.
By the way,
I'm going to be in a Saint Petersburg,
Florida at the Mahaffey theater.
They added a late show this Friday night.
It's going to be me,
uh,
Rosebowl Tailgate Legend,
Aka the,
uh,
the crown royal kid,
Joe Barton.
Nick.
That's his new nickname,
the crown royal kid.
He just got signed to a three year deal.
Um,
Paul [inaudible],
Paul Dude,
I called it Versie.
Whatever you do,
do not bring up that as giants are o and four.
Okay.
He's very sensitive.
We're going to be down there.
Uh,
and Thursday night I'm going to the Patriots for Tampa game.
I'm going to be respectful.
I'm not wearing my patriots gear because I don't wanna listen to everybody
giving me shit.
I don't need all that shit.
Even if we were undefeated,
I still wouldn't wear it.
I,
I've learned,
I just,
I just go there.
I silently route from my fucking team of Tampa wins.
I say congratulations.
Who gives a fuck?
This is the last NFL team that I need to see a home game of.
And then I'll have gone to all the baseball and all the,
all the football at a professional level.
And uh,
in my world of doing horrible in school and going to colleges,
uh,
numerous colleges during my college career,
none of which,
oh,
I went to NC state for my first,
my freshman year.
Um,
sort of what's in the off campus program.
I literally fucking drove into the library and watch the classes on cassette
tape.
Like I had some sort of fucking terminal disease.
That was my first semester and second semester I had two classes,
both of which I flunked because by then I decided I didn't want to be in North
Carolina.
So I sorta went there.
Um,
this is back when NC state wolf pack had like a Chucky Brown and Charles,
I think it was Charles Shackleford,
I believe they still had grass seats in the end zone.
I went to a Carolina a state game there.
Then I went to a couple other schools,
uh,
ended up in Emerson.
Emerson,
I don't even know what to fucking mascot is.
I have no idea what it is a,
anyways,
it's like a final draft software with some shit.
The fuck am I talking about?
Yeah.
So I'm going to be in a Saint Petersburg and then I'm going to own,
on Saturday,
we're going to the Florida gators for us.
Lsu Mighty Lsu.
So I will be silent.
He rooting for,
I liked Florida too,
but I'll be rooting for Lsu.
Man.
I can't fucking just cause they lost to the sunbelt Trojans the fuck.
Uh,
but I get to go to the legendary swamp and a,
I actually love both those teams,
but a,
I decided to hitch my wagon to Lsu so I can't just like fucking jump.
I will,
I,
you know,
I'm not going to be a cunt on either one of those.
I'm just going to be happy to be at that legendary field.
Um,
the at the swamp and then also to be at the,
uh,
pirates of the Caribbean stadium stadium at the Tampa Bay Buccaneers planned.
Um,
all right.
Lewis Hamilton on HBO.
Hey Bill.
Big Fan.
Just wanted to let you know that Lewis Hamilton is going to be featured on Hbo
Real Sports Tonight.
I got to watch that.
Uh,
if you miss it,
I'm sure you,
you can,
uh,
I'm sure you can watch it later on.
Demand.
Keep doing your thing.
Love F is for family and the podcast is a weekly ritual for me.
Best wishes to you and your growing family.
Oh,
thank you very much.
I'm going to try to check that out.
I saw,
I follow Louis Hamilton on Twitter and I saw that he,
uh,
he had some announcement to make and it looked like he was wearing some moto GP
suit and he was walking to a,
towards a motorcycle.
Now there's no fucking way the Mercedes team is going to let them do that,
right?
I don't think so.
So I don't know what the announcement was made.
We'd said he got another diamond stud for his other side.
It was,
knows,
I have no idea.
I don't pretend to live in that man.
Stratosphere.
I live in the troposphere.
He lives in the stratosphere.
Alright.
The Buccaneers logo,
everybody.
A bullet bill.
Uh,
the original Buccaneers logo was taking from the school.
I went to Beloit college.
They settled in court and Beloit one because the school has been around before
the NFL.
Uh,
the school is big in the liberal arts culture and the conversation of changing
the mascot due to the barbaric history of the Buccaneers,
uh,
the school actually has two mascots and official and unofficial.
Unofficial is a turtle and they're trying to see if they can make it the
official mascot over the buccaneer.
Good Lord.
I could,
I could give a fuck about it.
But how would you feel if the Patriots were to change to a pussy animal?
First of all,
I fucking love turtles.
If you don't like turtles,
man,
this,
there's something wrong with you.
They're awesome.
They don't bug anybody.
And if you think they're pussies,
go out and go get bit by one.
Um,
I fucking love turtles.
I add one is a pet and I went to church and I came home and it drowned.
Name was Ralph and I buried it in the fucking woods.
I never got another one.
Uh,
thanks for bringing it up a bit.
Anyways,
some pussy animal because they're associated with white nationalists or
whatever.
Grotesques historical events that is beyond our control.
Um,
the funny thing about that is all the liberal white people that go along with
doing that shit do not want to give up their land or their flat screen TVs.
I get,
you know,
so as a,
as a a halfassed,
you know,
gesture,
they're going to get rid of the mascot.
Like obviously I feel the Redskins.
I mean it's literally like a racial slur,
so I get that one.
But,
uh,
this other shit,
I mean,
I dunno,
liberal people want to get rid of it,
but I feel that's kind of a way of,
uh,
getting away with being [inaudible] as you're kind of getting rid of the
evidence.
You know,
if they had the buccaneer on the side,
they'd be like,
well,
who's that?
And be like,
Oh yeah,
that was a group of white people that came over here and just massacred a bunch
of fucking people.
Just took a bunch of shit.
They were evil.
They were evil in for all I know.
Uh,
you are one of their descendants,
but if you just make it all go away and it's just a turtle.
I Dunno.
I think they give human beings too much credit.
Like you have to understand that we're kind of out of our fucking minds.
Um,
some something,
some of it has to do with power.
I don't know what it is,
but,
uh,
I dunno.
We get too
much power.
You,
we behave like those fucking chimpanzees when they go out and hunt the other
monkeys.
You know what I mean?
I'll never fucking get over watching that.
I just,
it's the human,
the way they get excited and the way they torture the other fucking monkey
rather than just kill the fucking thing is a,
is a level of like sit down.
That's why I don't like cats.
I don't like how they just won't kill the mouse.
How the fucking things freaking,
I just put it out of its fucking misery.
They want,
still want to have fun with it.
MMM.
Like if somebody said we're descendants of cats,
I'd be like,
yeah,
I fucking believe that.
Where are we sneaking up on each other?
Trying to stab one another,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
I respect cat,
so,
you know,
I respect them all.
I'm just saying,
you know,
step behaviors is fucking weird.
Anyways,
he says,
love the fuck out of the podcast and listening since 2011 and followed your
comedy since.
Why do I do this?
Uh,
thank you for all the labs.
Hope your family's doing well and go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
my baby girl had a little bit of the sniffles do an a baby as a cold and it's
sneezes.
It's the funniest shit ever.
They don't cover their mouth and just,
it's fucking unreal.
It's like poltergeist and uh,
what's that?
What's that?
Nickelodeon slimed.
Um,
so if you've got a baby,
uh,
somebody told me this is good advice was just to get like a,
a face cloth and have it wet.
Just,
you know,
dab at it so you don't make their nose all raw and all that stuff.
Obviously frequently rinse it out,
change it.
I know this is disgusting,
but it was kind of what I was doing.
Um,
I feel like I gave her the cold cause I came back from Toronto and I felt like I
had was fighting off something and I'm not going to not hug and kiss my daughter
is that my daughter.
Right.
So I was hanging out with her and uh,
Neil was out with some friends this weekend,
so it was kind of a,
I get to be the single dad and I got to tell you,
man,
I fucking loved it,
you know,
I dunno what these single parents are complaining about.
I did it for about eight hours and I didn't have a problem at all.
No,
it was awesome.
She watched them,
the Formula One race with me and she watched the Patriots game.
I got a patriots one Z.
Um,
I think it said little but awesome or something like that.
Has the Patriot logo on it and whenever it's football Sunday.
And what's cool is Nia is not into sports and shit.
So she didn't want her to have a bunch of sports shit,
but I just bought it anyways.
And uh,
she fought for like two seconds.
He's like,
all right,
if you're into that,
fine,
she gets it,
she gets it.
So that's what it is.
Football Sunday,
I come home,
she's got two different patriots onesies.
I got to get her a Bruins one for the season coming up and all it's playoff
baseball.
Joe Bucket,
his finest,
um,
efforts for families.
Joe Buck add his finest.
I'm looking forward to that.
Crossing my fingers for a Yankees.
Red Sox match up another classic series.
Who knows who wins this,
you know,
I don't know how many times we played this year,
but we were dead even if we played 18 times.
We went nine and nine
and I got it to be interesting,
serious cause I haven't seen price be able to beat the fucking Yankees at least
in the second half when I was paying attention.
So we'll see.
Uh,
how many home runs did judge end up with?
I love all the people that have given him shit.
I was so happy that he got fucking 50.
These fucking cops,
dude.
I'm telling you.
Did they say that the home run Derby fucks up your swing?
I was that what they say?
So what they say?
You know,
you're not a football scout,
are you all right Aaron,
judge.
All fucking rise court is in session.
Have you reached a verdict?
We get it.
His last name's judge Aaron.
Judge stats.
Here we go.
I know we've got 50.
What did he finish with?
Yeah.
Oh,
runs 50 fucking toe.
Holy Shit.
That is fucking amazing.
52 home runs.
I don't know everybody give him shit about a strikeout.
Gives a fuck.
Yeah.
114 rbis.
Hundred 27 base on balls.
208 strikeouts.
52 home runs.
You had 542 at bats
and he had to,
he still hit two 84 with two oh 208 strikeouts.
He's still at two 84.
It's fucking amazing.
What a season graduations to him.
I hope he beat you.
I hope he be,
if we fucking,
you know,
and I'm gonna,
I'm not one of those cats that can't recognize greatness.
That's fucking amazing.
All right,
dear Billy button nose.
Uh,
thought this was interesting and new French law says that photo's must come with
a disclaimer
that they're photo shopped.
I love the French.
I fucking love the French.
You know what I mean?
You know why?
Cause they fucking go on around having threesomes and they're sick of being
excited about bringing somebody else into their relationship and they don't look
like the fucking picture.
You know what I mean?
I get it.
Anyways.
It's being done to discourage unhealthy extreme thinness among people trying to
emulate unrealistic body shapes that were faked with the computer program.
All right,
so it was a little off the mark on that.
Um,
this could really change the landscape from models,
right?
There's a sports equivalent in there somewhere.
Uh,
love you love Nia,
keep up the good work.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think that's probably,
that's not for adults.
That's for more.
Uh,
I think that's for kids.
Cause I noticed,
you know,
when I went to Toronto I couldn't believe how good looking the people were.
And I've just been going around in general just noticing how good looking people
are.
And I was just like,
what the fuck is going on?
And what I,
I think it is,
it's,
I think it's an a result of everybody being on social media and you post a
picture yourself in,
you know,
all this stuff that you didn't about yourself and then shit that you didn't even
recognize that,
that evidently people,
other people notice in comments.
Okay.
You know,
hey dude,
you fucking nice new profile picture.
But I got us,
I got to ask what's up with your right ear?
What's up with that shirt?
What's up at the blah,
blah,
you know,
and then it's unreal.
And then you start getting like a fucking complex.
Um,
social media is
okay
other than promoting.
Um,
but anyways,
I just feel like for me,
social media,
I promote gigs and I go on and I try to make people laugh.
That's it.
But to actually go on there and look at comments,
it's just not a healthy thing.
I don't think it's healthy for anybody.
Even if you're the most beautiful fucking person in the world because you know,
at some point you're going to start to go down the other side and then the
comments,
hey,
you're still hot.
But you starting to look starting to show your age there.
Lol.
Just kidding.
You know,
I love you.
That's all.
Somebody who's got nothing,
nothing but fucking complements,
needs to hear,
and then it's just a downward spiral into fucking botox and all of that shit.
Um,
yeah.
If I could promote anything,
uh,
just fucking,
just active goddamn age,
that's the best way to do it.
Just as,
as you're in your forties,
dress like you're in your forties,
keep yourself in good fucking shape.
This is certain number you hit and the best she can be at that point is you look
good for your age.
And if somebody says that to you,
it's a fucking compliment.
You got to be young.
You weren't cheated.
All right?
Stop trying to fucking hang on by your fingernails.
It's fucking over.
Let young people be young.
Let them have this,
whatever the fuck it is they're doing with those God damn Djs.
I don't get it,
but it's their shit.
Let him have it stopped showing up with your botox face asking if anybody has
any Molly.
Okay,
you're creeping people out.
All right.
It's over.
Mike.
My public service announcement is over.
All right.
Apocalypse prep.
Hey,
Bill.
Recently,
my girlfriend got mad that I don't have anything prepared in case of a hurricane
or a massive flood.
I'm not naive,
but we live in Kansas City.
I told her that while I have a flashlight,
extra cases of water and a generator,
not bad for a 25 year old homeowner,
that's pretty fucking great.
And you own a home at 25.
Congratulations.
Um,
I don't have a box titled Apocalypse Shit.
She said,
I never think about the future.
Oh boy.
I told,
you know.
Well,
you know,
at least she's not asking for a kid we made,
I don't think about the future.
I bought a house.
Okay.
You're dizzy.
Broad.
Uh,
I told her that a gas power generator is literally a symbol for the future.
you talk about this stuff all the time,
but if you actually got anything ready,
thanks.
Ps.
Love the music and the throwbacks.
Uh,
well,
Andrew Feminist,
he's the one that picks out the music.
Um,
I,
I bought some shit.
I bought some bucket of fucking food that you know would last forever and like
the lid on the bucket,
um,
also doubled as a toilet seat and you could shit in the bucket.
But then I don't know where your food went.
I went down the rabbit hole,
you know,
about 10 years ago,
thinking about,
you know,
uh,
going off the grid and fucking buying gold and silver coins and all of this
shit.
And then I was just,
then I just went the other way and I was just like,
you know,
I don't think I want to survive the apocalypse.
I'm fine if I'm laying in the street,
you know what I mean?
Cause then I would just live this unbelievable quality life.
And then once the apocalypse hit and everything sucked,
I wouldn't have to fucking live through it.
You know,
you're like,
when I'll fucking player.
Okay.
Like a
okay.
Say Like Doc rivers,
like,
you know,
he won a championship with the Celtics and then they totally dismantled the
team.
He's like,
dude,
I,
I'm too fucking old to go through a rebuilding year.
That's how I feel with like society.
Okay.
It's just been great.
Every fucking day of my life.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just,
you know.
Okay.
My fucking dresser drawer is full of championship rings.
I got to live in this country looking at how I looked.
I fucking lucked out.
Okay.
I'm not going to fucking lie to you.
I lucked out.
So follow that shit goes away.
You know what I mean?
And everything just collapses and then fucking prisoners a car.
I'm not going to fucking survive that.
So that'll be yet.
You know what I mean?
I'd fucking down a bottle of booze and then just turn the style.
I guess it's different now that I've got a family.
I Dunno.
Maybe I'll buy a generator.
All right.
Movie Lines.
I gave you one this week.
See She,
she uh,
day Billy Bass drum.
Uh,
this is the best line from a sub.
Can we,
can we talk bass drums here for a second?
Everybody I know has a different fucking way of tuning the Goddamn Bass Drum.
Yeah.
What is your,
what is the way that you do it?
Do you get a good sound out of it?
I just had somebody blew my fucking mind when I thought it was you just tuned
the batter head.
Okay.
You know,
that was the one that I thought you put a little tension too.
And then I thought the other side,
you just fucking,
you know,
just
okay.
You know,
tightened it past the wrinkle.
Alright.
Cause Hey,
you wanted to,
you want to move that air,
right?
You also want to have,
I dunno,
fuck the fucking beat or have something to rebound off of.
And uh,
then I met somebody and he fucking tells me the exact opposite thing.
And then I met somebody this weekend and he goes back the other way.
I don't know what the fuck to do.
All I know is my bass drum tuning sucks.
So,
um,
whatever,
I'm going to give it another shot.
I'm just gonna you just have to have the balls to just,
just keep on doing it and doing it back again.
And then just dealing with whatever shit sound you come up with and each time
hopefully getting it a little bit better.
But,
um,
I'm always open to listen to people.
Uh,
any ideas you have,
please let me know.
All right,
dear Billy Bass drum,
this is the best line from a supporting character in a movie is from Wayne's
world too.
There's nothing vulgar so you can play it on air.
Wayne and Garth had brought a roadie back from the UK to help put a concert put
on a concert while hanging out.
He tells them this crazy story,
rock and roll story about Ozzy,
Jeff Beck and Keith Richards.
Give it a listen.
All right,
let's hope there's no fucking racial slurs in this like there was last week.
Um,
okay.
Or some reason the link isn't working.
Okay.
Oh,
why I want the link work.
Where is it?
Oh,
you know what,
I,
I have to go over here.
Hang on,
I'll hit pause so you don't have to torture your way through this.
All right,
we're back.
Here we go.
Here it is air.
It is.
Come on
at three o'clock in the morning.
Look you for 1000 Brown m and m's to fill up the glass so you wouldn't go on
stage.
No one's going to be able to hear this dude.
Yeah,
I don't know why it's super fucking quiet.
What's going on here?
Okay.
I got all the volumes up.
Oh,
I know this thing.
And that's when he,
in the end he said,
uh,
you know,
he goes into the store to go buy him.
He would need to buy chocolate m and m's to fill up into Ozzie's brandy glass.
And he goes there and,
and the,
the place was closed and they had some dog.
You fights off the dog and then he had the murder,
the owners with their own shoes.
Right.
I think that's what it is.
I'm sorry dude.
I don't know if anybody can hear this.
Can you heron
sweet the ship on the edge of town we got,
and it's just me and Keith and David Crosby branch it into this local sweet
shop.
Well,
instead of a gun,
they've got this bloody great big thing.
Well,
I'll manage to take care of the choice to go with a channel,
but the shop phone,
her and his son,
that's a different story altogether.
All right.
To beat them to death with the one shoe.
There you go.
Nasty business,
isn't it?
I never watched it.
I know I never saw Wayne's world.
That was great when I started doing standup,
so I fucking missed out on it.
It was too busy trying to get on stage.
Oh,
by the way,
the ticket link for the all things comedy podcast festival is in Phoenix,
is up@billboard.com for the first time ever.
I am going to do a live Monday morning podcast.
Now the first thing is to be asking yourself as like,
you're going to have a guest?
No.
Are you going to address the no.
I'm going to go out there.
I'm going to get a bed and I'm just going to lay down in it.
You guys are fucking sit there and watch it.
I don't know if it's going to work,
but we'll see.
We'll see.
It's going to be more like a play.
It's going to have headphones on.
I'm going to block out people laughing.
Um,
I'm probably,
I have to react to the crowd,
but I'm not going to be fucking going out there doing stand up or any of that.
I'm going to sit down and I'm just going to fucking do my part.
You again,
if you're just going to be able to watch it.
I got to have some sort of commemorative tee shirt or a poster or some shit,
but that is going down in Phoenix,
Arizona fee.
I've never done the video thing I did at one time and it at the all things
comedy podcast I guess I did at one time,
but if you ever wanted to see what the fuck this shit looks like,
um,
who knows.
Maybe it won't work.
Like rap,
like rap live.
Remember when I'm in,
sorry,
wrap with a live band.
I mean that when they tried to do that unplugged you only guy who ever pulled it
off was ll cool j.
He pulled it off.
Everybody else.
It just never,
it just didn't fucking work.
You got to add the guy on the turntables.
Um,
I'm probably wrong about that but I just said it and I'm going to stick by it.
All right.
Fat phobic.
Dear Billy Backbreaker,
I'm a 28 year old white male living in Ohio.
I had been single for nearly four years now.
Congratulations.
I consider myself to be an active guy.
Rock climbing,
going to the gym.
Is this like your Tinder fucking bullshit and you're sending me,
I like to rock climb,
go to the gym,
cycling,
et Cetera.
Anyways,
I used to be overweight at 250 pounds and over the course of a year I was able
to get down to 172 pounds.
It maintain that due to the activeness and eating a plant based diet.
Good for fucking you,
sir.
Making me fuck you're inspiring me.
Good for you man.
What a great thing you did.
My situation is this.
I have some ladies that have expressed interest in me.
However,
the majority of them are overweight and have no self control when it comes to
their diet and exercise.
I'm not attracted to bigger women,
which puts me in a difficult situation when they very openly flirt and invite me
out.
Why?
You're not attracted to them.
That's totally fine and it's totally fine to not be into overweight people.
I don't know why.
You have to pretend that you're in the people that you're not into.
So the person,
you know,
eating the fucking Drake's cake can feel good about themselves.
What about you?
There's still a victim in there.
Okay.
And considering being on a shape is curable for most people.
I'm not saying it's not a disease,
but for most people they do what you do.
Plant based Diet.
They get active and to fucking falls off.
Plus considering you are a fatty,
this is like an alcoholic.
You know who got sober,
you're going to go hang out with an alcoholic.
I guarantee you'll become a fat fuck hanging out with them.
All right?
And that way you're going to be,
you're going to be laying down and she tries to ride you on top.
I hope you got enough to fucking still get it in there.
You to belly slapping together.
You don't have to be part of that,
do you?
Uh,
the ladies can turn down men,
no problem.
But when a man turns down a lady,
some of the ladies I work with in their close friends,
I've known for years,
some of the ladies I work with and are close friends I've known for years.
Well,
why the fuck would you date them anyways?
They know that I've been single for four years.
Honestly,
I am picky and I've also learned to be happy after multiple bad relationships.
Dude,
you are fucking crushing life right now.
Don't fuck it up by dating some fatty that you work with because society is
telling you that you're not progressive if you don't.
Anyway,
so when I deny a date request or don't flirt back with them,
they say that I'm fat phobic.
Is this what this has come to?
Um,
like if some fat fucking mantated Douche came walking up to them pressing his
dick up against,
I mean that's what the fuck they're doing to you
sticking their fucking clam in your face.
Smelling like a Jim Dandy Sunday at friendlies.
Right?
They didn't,
what the fuck?
Fuck off.
I'm not fat phobic.
I just weighed 172 pounds and I know that I can get a better fucking cut of
meat.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to go.
That means I'm just saying cause the Fed phobic piss me off.
All right,
you should respect everybody.
Just say,
listen.
Um,
I used to be fat like you and I started rock climbing.
Why don't you rock climb?
Okay.
Or at least maybe just stare at a bunch of rocks instead of eating rocky road
ice cream every fucking weekend.
Maybe I'll throw your bang every once in a while is dice clay says not troll a
bank.
Yeah.
Dude,
can I tell you something right now,
this fucking woman's movement thing is completely out of control.
It's completely out of control.
They are not all of them,
but so many of them are everything that they're fucking preaching that they
don't want guys to do to them,
okay?
There,
you know you have the absolute 100% right to date.
Whoever the fuck you want to date.
You have the right to be as shallow as you fucking want to be.
You could date for looks for 10 fucking years if you want to before you want to
settle down and get serious.
You know,
and if you wait too long,
you're going to pay the price.
But it's your life.
The linen.
This is,
this is your fucking life,
dude.
You're going to date some fucking fatty and you don't want to just so what the,
those constant work,
we'll look at you in a better way.
I,
I wouldn't do that.
Just be like,
yeah,
my dance card is full.
All right,
this,
these are the measurements I like and I'm not ashamed of it.
Okay?
That's what I find attractive
as do you,
can I tell you something?
All of those women at work,
if they could be the size that you find attractive would be,
you know what I mean?
And they ate their way into that position.
It's their job to eat the way out.
The same way you did.
So you had to get on a bike,
you had to climb a bunch of rocks,
you had to do all this shit.
Now you're,
you're in game shape,
right?
You're fucking in Colby Bryan shape and there's showing up like shack and they
want to try to play their way into shape.
Remember Colby stories give check shit for doing that.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Anyways,
he says,
I've never pointed out their weight,
but when I have openly expressed interest in other women while talking to the
other guys at work,
that women start to shame me.
All right,
dude.
You know what?
I was on your side until you said shame.
What it,
what the fuck happened to him?
What happened to people?
They shame you.
You just fucking laugh at them saying that.
Only like bones and twigs.
Uh,
I get along with everybody so I never strike back.
What's your problem with anything in fear that I might be taken to HR for God
knows what in days.
Also having denied some of the women they've gone as far as to not speak to me
as much until other female core coworkers.
How horrible of a man I am.
Leaving them to have bad attitudes against me just because I won't date them.
Uh,
do,
what do you look like,
Burt Reynolds?
What the fuck's going on here?
I would,
uh,
yeah.
Listen,
this is the deal.
Women go to HR guys,
just laugh at it.
So just laugh at it,
dude.
You know what I would do?
I would be overly friendly to the ones that hate me.
You know,
morning.
So you look lovely today.
Kill them with kindness.
And then I would bring the most smoking hot fucking chick you could find to the
fucking Christmas party.
That's what you got to do anyways.
He says it's true.
I'm not attracted to big a women.
That's fine.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But women sit around all day talking about guys having to be this tall,
have this fair,
she'll hair,
wear these clothes.
But when a man has any sort of criteria,
we get shamed.
Dude,
stop saying that.
Okay?
Being shamed is totally within your own power at the age that you're at.
If you're a fucking teenager or younger,
I get it.
All right?
But at some point you gotta be comfortable with how you look.
Okay?
You got to get comfortable with yourself and then someone can't shame you unless
you actually did something shameful.
Yeah.
If he kicked the puppy across the room,
you know what I mean?
You don't want to be comfortable enough with yourself that you can handle the
criticism and have it not affect.
You should feel shame.
All right.
Anyways,
he goes,
I'm writing to hopefully get your take on the matter and hear what you would do
in this situation.
I will never see desiring of fit healthy person who about their body as a bad
thing.
No,
you shouldn't.
And that's something that all people should aspire to be fit and in shape,
healthier than they were yesterday as much as you can.
I,
you know,
obviously the aging process,
you're getting older every second one step closer to the grave.
Right.
But,
you know,
in the meantime,
yeah.
Uh,
thanks for all the good laughs.
You and Nia are the friends.
I wish I had real life.
That's so nice.
Have a good day and go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
Dude.
It,
by the way,
that goes for women too,
goes for women too.
All right.
Um,
yeah,
Dave,
what the fuck you want to date?
And if you want to be shallow,
you know,
in dish date hot people that just do that.
See what that's like.
It's up to you.
I don't understand.
You know what I mean?
Like the,
you know what you have at work,
dude,
you have a bunch of busy bodies,
you know,
and there's these people out there that want to be the person to say I age it is
this person to that person.
Um
Oh dude,
I swear to God man.
I swear to God,
you find the hottest fucking check you can fucking find.
You could fucking fine.
Take it to the God damn Christmas party.
And by the way,
let her know what's up.
Let her know what's up.
I would say I would fight,
I would tell some fucking,
I would tell some hot chick that whole fucking story and you know,
hot chicks love being hot.
Nothing that they would make them feel hotter than to go down there and have a
bunch of women look at her and just hate her because how fucking hot she is.
There you go.
Find that check.
Maybe she's into sports too.
Next thing you know,
you guys are running the country,
not the country,
that company.
That's perfect.
Ah,
it's a fan of see,
but maybe you can make it happen,
sir.
Um,
good luck to you.
Good luck to you.
And that's it.
And by the way,
there's plenty of guys out there that like big women,
you know what I mean?
That's plenty.
It's up to you to be happy with your own fucking body.
All right up telling you,
telling you just fucking have a salad,
have one fucking salad a day.
Start fucking working out.
Read up as much as you can on nutrition.
Try the best you can.
Eat the best food you can,
which is really difficult,
you know,
so he could do then.
Other than that,
leave people alone and let them date.
Who the fuck they want a date.
Um,
all right,
that is the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
And A,
I'll give you my fucking pick of the week on Thursday.
That's it.
When I'm in Tampa up,
up,
up our Thursday night football.
Oh God.
They're going to be wearing those ugly,
under rude fucking jerseys.
What do they call them?
The a full court press jerseys,
whatever the fuck they call them.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
All a check in on you on Thursday.